Michael malice has a a hierarchy of
different uh I think it's like the
hierarchy of grifters don't know why the
moment you say Michael malice my face
immediately sort of starts to smile yeah
it's terrible one of the it's like um
industry plant paid opposition
controlled scop he goes all the way up
and he said that he descended recently
he's not quite at paid opposition but I
think he's industry plant now I think
Lex Freedman is paid opposition um is
paid is different from controlled
opposition maybe it's controlled
opposition I don't [__] know
controlled opposition is these are such
weird terms that have cropped up in our
era I love it again I think there's sort
of low resolution explanations for
really really low resolution
explanations for things whenever I hear
somebody describe things as that I
always sort of know you're not dealing
with somebody who actually understands
the world do you find there's a
definitely a trend of um conspiratorial
thinking conspiracism uh much stronger
in our adopted Homeland than it is in
the UK I think yes that's
true what do you think are you how
conspiracy pilled are you do you
see I mean it's it's this is the moment
when people say ah controlled
opposition you've ascended this is me
allowing you to graduate from I think I
talked about this on the boys cast
that's right and and brief briefly and
and and uh various people wrote to me
saying ah there you go that's proof that
you're paid you're glowing as it's
called but it's what it you're you heard
you're glowing no what's it so tell me
if I'm wrong with this Mark you're the
resident glow expert but you're glowing
means you're you're like
a
planted person who's saying something
that is outing their
like oh it's an intelligence operation
that's that's breached the surface and
people can see it they comment on Tik
Tok saying like you're glowing oh it's
like um the people alleged to be FBI um
who are at certain protest or wearing
chinos and t-shirts yeah um so your
conspiratorial so the conspir the thing
with conspiracy theories is very
difficult in our era because some of the
conspiracies are true of course have
come true um well known to be true uh
lab leak conspiracy theory probably true
they shouldn't have ever called nobody
should ever have called it a conspiracy
theory it wasn't a conspiracy theory it
was one of a set of hypo of
hypotheticals to explain what happened
with uh with uh with covid um so a lot
of things get called conspiracy which
are not they're just hypotheses uh that
should be allowed to remain on the table
and that makes a certain type of person
increasingly prone to uh believe that
everything that's called a conspiracy
theory is not a conspiracy theory and
before you know it you get sanish
individuals thinking that the
moonlandings were a conspir
we didn't land on the moon the American
didn't land on the moon I don't know
whether the people who now claim that
believe that the Russians also faked it
it's an interesting question to ask them
do you think the the that the Soviets
were capable of getting to the moon but
the Americans were not the Americans set
up like a a blow fan and a flag on a
dodgy papia mese set but the Soviets did
make it or did the Soviets and Americans
both agree to pretend to have gone to
the moon but not really have gone none
of it makes sense to my mind but but but
but it's I have noticed and well it's
actually all the literature demonstrates
this that there's certain types of
mental um uh uh problems that people
have that make them disproportionately
likely to believe conspiracy theories on
on mass and one of them is paranoia uh
the more paranoid a person is the more
likely they to believe that sort of
thing and that's the observation in my
own life I've I've known a number of
people who who've gone into the world of
conspiracy and not come out and they are
all people who have suffered paranoid
episodes in their lives so which adds up
so fear and genders yeah and it's as I
say it's a sort of low resolution
explanation for complex
phenomena uh and you know and I think
it's also that see conspiracy theories
come about and and are used by people
who and this is isn't an original Point
many people have made it they're made
the claims about them are made by and
large by people who don't understand how
unbelievably chaotic the world actually
is or can't face
it um so they can't face the fact that
yeah somebody you followed in the
newspapers every day all of your life
did actually just die in a Freak Car
Crist because the driver was drunk they
can't bear the idea the world can't be
that cruel it can't be that
random you want a bed it's got to be
coordination it can't be coincidence
exactly so people who can't cope with
the wild frivolity of the roulette table
of Our
Lives um always go to the there must be
somebody behind it there must be
somebody who's controlling all this you
you joking nobody's controlling this if
anyone's controlling the damn thing I'd
want to know by now but of course
they're not it's it's so it's a very
unsatisfactory place to arrive at in
your life and by the way my own
observation it's not very good for
people personally because they they
start to lose agency themselves locus of
control gets externalized I'm at the
mercy of the world yeah and the real
answer is the world doesn't care no
doesn't even know that you exist it is
De to you
the the ability for people to hold two
conflicting thoughts in their mind at
the same time is supposed to be the mark
of of sophisticated thinking but it does
show up here which is the government is
both so useless that they can't get
anything right and so sophisticated that
they're able to coordinate that's masses
of versions the Arab world is filled
with that the Muslim world is filled
with that things like uh I've notic this
repeatedly on my travels things like um
uh 911 was an inside job of the
Americans to allow the Jews out of the
World Trade Center and also yay 911 good
for bin Laden they can do both uh there
was a somebody I knew interviewed the
father of um the main 911 hijacker his
name's gone out of my mind I don't care
he must he should be forgotten but
interviewed the father in Jordan and he
was simultaneously capable of holding in
his head that his son was a great Shahid
a m for
Islam and that 911 was an inside job of
the
Americans what what the [__] like
choose it's I mean do you think your son
was an agent of the FBI and also a
martyr like hey people do this the
Muslim world is particularly prone to to
conspiratorial thinking because it's a
it's a source of flattery to ex to
explain why they have created so few
successful
societies um and and Bernard Lewis made
this point many years ago that the
problem in the Muslim world is that
there's a they is they have to find
explanations because if you're given the
revelations of Muhammad and you're told
it's the last Revelation ever from God
and that you are the people who have
received this Revelation and
everything's going to go great for you
because you've got the Revelation and
then like the Jews you have one country
and it does much better than any of your
countries and you know you can't get the
economy of most your countries going at
all and you can't provide for most of
your citizenry and nobody's coming up
the ladder and the economies in the dust
and all this you've got to find an
explanation for it because like what we
were given the Revelation and they're
doing much better soan there's massive
things like that that sit underneath the
movements of our time
which maybe billions of people on the
planet believe and they believe them
because it flatters themselves it
flatters the governments who aspire to
run these countries or claim to run
these
countries um yeah billions of people
believe this [__] in other news this
episode is brought to you by Maui newie
venison Maui Nei venison brings the
healthiest red meat on the planet direct
to your door not only is it the most
nutrient-dense meat on the planet
they're the only 100% stress-free wild
harvested venison that you can get
here's my super secret hack if you are
sick of buying meat that always goes off
put it in the freezer from Frozen salt
both sides of it put it in an air fryer
for 10 to 12 minutes each side and you
have a perfectly cooked steak from
Frozen that will never go off because
it's going from freezer to mouth in the
space of 25 minutes it's a complete Game
Changer all of their cuts are
spectacular and you can get them Frozen
delivered to your door but their venison
sticks are my favorite while I've been
on the road you can get the healthiest
red meat on the planet delivered
directly to your door and get 20% off by
going to the link in the descript
description below or heading to mauw
venison tocom slod wisdom and using the
code modern wisdom check out that M AI
nuui venison docomo wisdom and modern
wisdom at checkout thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
with Douglas you will love the 2hour
long podcast episode which you can watch
right
here go
on